не залишила роботу розширене засідання
колегії Міністерства освіти і науки
молоді і спорту України розглянула два
найголовніше питання перше це стан
готовності навчальних закладів в Україні
до нового навчального року і друге це
стан впровадження
нових стандартів початкової школи адже
нагадаємо з 1 вересня
міністрів ще в квітні 2011 року
затверджений новий державний стандарт
початкової школи всі школи України 1
класу починають працювати по-новому долю
нових державних стандартів
відповідно до закону Про освіту загальну
середню освіту яке вимагає закон
міністерством розроблені обговорили
створення разом з національною академією
педагогічних наук нові державний
стандарт
оскільки я йду у всіх представників
засобів масової інформації читали ці
стандарти як коротко нагадаю їх
змістовну частину чому їх новація і
революційність ну по-перше згідно нового
державного стандарту всі діти в Україні
починають вивчати іноземну мову з
першого класу 2
всі тільки України почнуть вивчати
інформатику починаючи з другого класу з
найпростішого інформаційного
інформаційного предмету сходинки до
інформатики
третя інновація цього стандарту
починаючи з п'ятого класу це з
наступного року з 1 вересня 2013 року
обов'язково вводиться лисички України
вивчення другої іноземної
всі одна новація цих стандартів усіх
початковій школі обов'язково в у урок
Кожен урок з будь-якого предмету буде
обов'язково мати дві фіззарядка
це особливо важливо для учнів першого
четвертого класу крім того при цьому
новому державному стандарту не вперше
виконали може цілої низки законів і
збільшили будильник на фізичну культуру
фізичний розвиток до трьох годин на
тиждень але не ви стандартів ще цікавить
що йому дуже велика варіативність
складова тобто
обов'язкова частина буде складати
Приблизно 50 відсотків навантаження
решта затверджених навчальних програм
можна конструювати сам педагогічний
колектив будь-якої середньої
загальноосвітньої школи тобто ця
варіативна частина вона Допоможе і
зробити підготовку діти більш якісне і
розкриє нові можливості для творчості
педагога у нього викладання
передбачається вже східних наступним
також затвердженим державним стандартом
базової середньої освіти яке охоплюють
5-9 клас і
державними стандартами старшої школи
частина предметів поступово буде
викладатися в середніх школах іноземною
мовою не примусово це за бажанням
педагогічного колективу якщо дійсно
ховається Я хотів би сказати що роботі
над новими державними стандартами
ці два роки в їх називаємо прискорений
марш ви провідних і він не просто
створення стандарту і затвердження до
створення нових українських підручників
і звичайно перепідготовки цілої низки
вчителю важливо що всі державні
стандарти були обговорені самим широким
загалом крім того одержали позитивну
оцінку міжнародних експертів так зокрема
в світі тепер та у Ради Європи
познайомитись з новими навчальними
програмами
вивченні іноземних мов Україні це на
земному з першого класу друга іноземна
мова свято села методики викладання і
можливість викладати англійську
предметів старшій школі назвав це свою
українські плані є справжнім
лінгвістичній одиниці
еее перед тим як розпочати роботу в
початковій школі по-новому стандарту
звичайно разом з національною академією
педагогічних наук і освітянами ми також
два роки а пробували і затверджений ще
одну важливу складову це базовий
компонент дошкільної освіти це також
новий державний стандарт прийоми
розроблені було вивчено краще світовий
досвід і
проведення широке громадське обговорення
документу
на базі цього стандарту було розроблено
затверджено програму у дітей старшого
дошкільного віку впевнений Старт і з
першого вересня програми державного стає
обов'язковим для всіх дошкільних
навчальних закладів України для
шкільної підготовки дітей від 5 до 6
років пиріжків нами про те що ще важливо
коли ми говоримо про дошкільну освіту
об'єкт проте більше двох років тому в
червні
2010 року не говорили про необхідність
про необхідність
постановки пріоритет розвитку дошкільної
освіти його можливих Хрестовий Похід за
повернення дитячих дошкільних закладів
дуже багато було суттєвості я можу
доповісти що за два роки в Україні стало
більше на
650 дитячих садків лише в першому
півріччі 2012 року відкрито нових і
відновили роботу 199
ми разом з додатковими з додатковими
групами на сьогоднішній день на
сьогоднішній день майже на
дітей дошкільного віку мають можливість
одержувати дошкільну підготовку і.і.
і насамкінець хотів би сказати що нас
відбулося спеціальне засідання Кабінету
Міністрів який було повністю присвячена
підготовці до нового навчального року що
дуже приємно що це свідчить про
пріоритет у роботі Кабінету Міністрів на
засіданні після всебічного обговорення
прем'єр-міністр України Микола Азаров
дав доручення всім міністерствам
державним комітетам центральним органом
виконавчої влади чи їх структурі ще
в дитячих дошкільних установах впродовж
року вирішити програму проблему їх
виселення і повернення і повернення всіх
дошкільних установ до вирішення Я думаю
що цю програму виконаємо впродовж
наступного року що таке черга до
дошкільного навчального закладу повністю
забудемо як там і звичайно Було в
дошкільних закладах трохи більше еее у
нас останні три роки і це дуже приємно
позитивно негативно або позитивно
демографічну ситуацію навіть цьому році
близько чотирьохсот 30б
у
першокласників
і насамкінець хотів би вас поінформувати
що сьогодні в засіданні колегії взяли
участь більше 200 освітян керівників
педагогів директорів шкіл з усіх
регіонів України Минулого року ми
проводили більш масою коли Але в цьому
році був інший підхід ми провели акцію
яку назвали всеукраїнського і вона
одержала дуже велику підтримку
освітянської громади на міжпланетна
міста на близько 400 тисяч педагогічних
працівників всіх без винятку областей на
два ні на один день на три дні вирушали
про своїх колег причому це обмін
областями несподівано Сумська Харків
Харківська
посольство такого не було якщо
полтавські освітяни будуть в Харківській
області Харківський Сумський відео але
освітяни іншого І вони познайомились у
своїх білих десь набралися оптимізму та
загалом в акції яка тривала липні-серпні
мусить брали участь в основу її були
покладені матеріали
опрацювання були покладені в основу
роботи колегії взяли участь у підготовці
колегії 25 тисяч освітян це чотири з
половиною тисячі які мандрували і
близько 20 з половиною тисяч з роботом
яких ми ним познайомились висоті ширині
можна сказати що початкова школа України
згуртував працювати за новими державними
стандартами всі підручники виготовлені
затверджені навчальні програми
підручники першого класу в повному
обсязі залежить до всіх шкіл А це чотири
з половиною мільйони підручників вчителі
знаходяться на своїх місцях немає вже
два роки поспіль проблеми з вакансіями
школі
навіть ін у світі зменшилась кількість
вакансій цифри й тому ми можемо говорити
Що по-новому за новим державним
стандартом початкової школи України
інтелекту цього Дякую я
не можу коментувати ти
деяких населених пунктах якщо є
конкретна ситуація населений пункт
область скарга батьків ми можемо щось
обговорювати деякі так би мовити
сирійських повстанців весь час
коментували що Президент Сирії перейшов
на їхній що він давав телеінтерв'ю і вже
не одне за кілька останніх днів деякі
випадки дуже важливим національним
у
природокористуванні ніякого відношення
до Міністерства освіти і науки молоді і
спорту немає Це університет який вперто
відстоюють свою дивовижну самостійність
Це єдині вищі навчальні заклади які
знаходяться в безпосередньому
підпорядкуванні Кабінету Міністрів Можу
порадити студентам звернутися за тих хто
має управлінську важелі впливу на цей
університет думаю що це безглуздя якби
це було у вищих навчальних закладах
нашої зі схем покарали ректора або
доганою обох фінансово a-toys
прихильники відповідає за гуртожитки
шукали собі інше місце але тут я можу
тільки поспівчувати
палата бачимо поки будь ласочка А ось ти
ще вчора казали про оцінювання учнів під
час уроків фізкультури це вже почнеться
буде залік не залік це вже з 1 вересня
почнеться і через будь ласка просто
Поясніть чому Значить ми маємо досить До
побачення нового державного стандарту
по-новому державному стандарту починає
працювати перший клас Тобто діти
першокласники наступного року вони
по-новому стандарту вчитися другому
класі і так далі так далі
для тих хто має дітей цікавився школу
всі знають що ніколи в першому класі не
було жодного предмета тому тут немає
ніякої новації як відключити дані я
твердо переконаний що здоров'я дитини
здоров'я дитини набагато важливіше ніж
будь-які оцінки тим більше з предмету
який має розвивати тому поступу
оцінка по фізкультурі буде просто
змінено на зарахована на відвідування це
не механічне зміни Я сьогодні говорив
матеріалах колегії вчителів важко
відучити від якоїсь примусово каральної
функції оцінки даному випадку а
передбачає новий державний стандарт ж
півтора рази котрій годині замість
обов'язково на тиждень уроку фізичної
культури
обов'язково дві фізичні вправи для
зарядки усім початковій школі і ми
будемо впроваджувати також обов'язково
прогулянкової уроку урок перебування на
свіжому повітрі Звичайно це не урок а це
просто Ну скажімо так заняття крім того
державний стандарт передбачає що
зарахування заняттях фізкультури може
бути для тих хто займається стежити за
спортивними танцями постійно відвідує
секцію і таке інше наше завдання якісно
змінити стан здоров'я дітей починаючи
вже з 1 вересня і я ще раз кажу що
першокласника вітати ціннісне ставлення
і вони відразу починають по-новому
стандарту ми будемо це поступово
впроваджувати
досвід багатьох кращих європейських і
світових шкіл говорить про те що їх
немає оцінки Ані за фізичну культуру і
музики і малювання люди обдаровані
скажімо краще малює ніжно я саме тому що
в дитинстві
малювати але сумління дитини позитивно
оцінювати і бажання бути на уроках
малювання і 300 історії живопису також
треба позитивно оцінювати в даному
випадку ця оцінка На мою думку
другорядна безумовно навіть богачом
вступом виступає
дуже просто скажи на сьогоднішній день
затримки заробітної плати ніде немає
сили адже цей зобов'язаний
забезпечити заробітна плата вчителя
міністр А
я знаю що працює спільно з міністерством
фінансів Чернігівська обласна державна
адміністрація щодо заяви управління
військового тієї чи іншої області для
мене ця новина Я думаю що
я вже про це сказала що початок
навчального року не уникне певної
політизації лише неодноразово чуємо коли
на білий будуть казати навіть не сірий А
чого і можливо цьому
місцеві органи влади місцеві державні
адміністрації повинні праці розраховуємо
це теж щодо додаткових підручників
будь-яка Людина має
право читати будь-яку книгу взагалі
Держава починається там де є
той ти введення про які ви говорите
ніякого відношення Ні до підручника Ні
до посібника немає воно не проходила
німі я не
одержував гриф Міністерства освіти ні в
якому вигляді
рекомендованим як допущені тому чому
люди спалюють
бюджетні кошти
дотацій на дотаційних бюджет Львівської
міської ради це питання не до мене А до
тих хто повинен контролювати законність
витрачання коштів державного бюджету
якщо хтось когось дратує
державного бюджету за рахунок внесків
всіх громадян України і всіх регіонів і
територій а той хтось дотації
використовує свавільно пара збирається
рахункова палата
державної фінансової інспекції
прокуратура України через теж у віданні
допускається в школі
будь-які Якщо воно відповідно пройшло
психологічну педагогічну апробацію
рекомендовані розглянула а велика
кількість фахівців ти видання про які ви
говорите до школи ніякого відношення